what i'm saying is i didn't give myself
excuses but you know not a reason i
found out a reason but it was also a
lack of self-control and discipline but
there was a reason for you right right
right but but the reason like the reason
behind the reason like why did i get to
that place in the first place
that's what i'm no no i'm saying before
before
the reason i was in the point where i
was eating foods that weren't nutrient
dense was a lack of self-control right
okay i love ice cream you know what i
mean
like i was and and you know a lot of the
foods that i was eating were like
microwavable foods right right so it was
a lack of self-control i was lazy i
didn't want to cook okay and and so but
that was me being lazy and taking
accountability for that gave me better
results and so it's not kind to bail out
women for their bad decisions because it
gives them worse results
in the long run but coddling women i'm
using the word that you used in in that
sense
do you feel like it has better results
as well because i don't feel like the
the tough laughing works of the matter
sure it's a short it's a it's a
short-term solution it's like a plot
it's like putting a plaster on you need
to expose the wound so that it can stay
aggressive because the thing is do you
have a son or a daughter a son have a
son okay so if he
got really obese
right
okay but let's say he's 15 he's really
obese right yeah and he's obese because
of a justifiable reason in your eyes
okay yeah right you're just gonna let
him be obese
or you're gonna try and no but the thing
is there's a reason there's a reason
okay but no no no one's saying there
isn't a reason right all we're saying is
that you are in control of your weight
right and so
anybody who is big
it is down to the decision they're in
control
i'm not disputing that okay so we agree
then you know we listen that's the thing
we agree my thing is maybe it's just
it's maybe it's the language we're using
that i'm struggling with
because i just no i agree because i just
feel like it's very cut and short and
that there's no gray area in what i feel
like you guys are saying concerning it
it's very much your big lose weight end
of but i think that's just not like the
reason why
you can't you can say that like that
could that could be the the surface
level right right but it can be okay
well you are big there may be reasons
behind it justifiable reasons that you
understand let's look into that then and
then that's where our solution will line
up
no no looking for the reason that's the
solution that's not the solution exactly
one at a time please thank you will be
in the reason but the idea right the
idea of being fat i understand it might
not be black and white right however you
can you can look for the reason it can
be whatever however the solution will
always be you probably need to eat less
like that's and that's what we're saying
that's what we're saying this is what
this is why i don't think we agree
because that's all i said if you're if
you're not eating you will lose weight
that's what i said if that was all you
said
i wouldn't
that was a whole point of the example
with countries with famine i just felt
like you weren't giving space for other
factors you made it sound like you are
big one plus one is two you are big lose
weight but
if if that black and white we'd we'd be
the thing is what we're saying
what was i think what we're saying is
the factors don't matter in the sense of
in the sense
no what i mean is the factors don't
matter in regards to what the solution
is exactly that's what we're saying i
disagree then i'm not disagreeing okay
because the fact is
the reason why the the the weight
problem was created in the first place
right and it's true the statement as to
you know the statement of your fact you
need to lose weight is a true it's a
good statement right and and the and uh
the truth behind that is that you have
to find out why you got fat for example
with you you said you were lazy right
mm-hmm and even with you as you said
with hormone hormone with emotional
um eating and disorders right we've got
to look at what uh
eating disorder really is you're feeling
some type of way there's some sort of
issues some emotional issues anxiety
whatever it is probably caused from
trauma or however it's happened
and instead of dealing with it
the person is choosing to fill that void
and kind of
did you hear that yeah
yeah so there's there's always a choice
there like you're feeling the emotions
but you have a choice to either address
their emotions or eat and stimulate
yourself and get fat well and all the
solutions are pretty much the same
though it's definitely eat healthy foods
eat less calories exercise that's my
point you'll be comfortable in your own
skin but you know it's also do nothing
and just stay fat
no but like if you don't find the cause
then you don't have
to solve it but you know why it's also a
choice because some people over eat
right some people over some people under
eat it started as a blanket thing that
people with that specific um ailment do
they don't just all over eat and so it
is a choice how you choose to you know
you decide to eat your feelings you
decide to go to the gym you start to
play games in order to wherever that
trauma was it's still a choice
and i think you have to be at peace you
have to be at peace with the decisions
you make so what i mean by that is if
you overeat as an example and you put on
weight you have to be at peace with the
fact that you might not be able to find
that high attainable man and you can't
moan about that so you just have to it's
ownership and accountability and i think
that's where the issue is accountability
i actually very much agree with you
because i don't want people to think
that i just hate fat people or anything
like that i'm not no no what i'm saying
is that we should put fat people in a
labor camp so we get free work and they
lose weight
what i'm actually saying is
i don't want people to
to think that i'm that's what i'm saying
what i'm actually saying is
if you are fat
your decisions led to that that's all
i'm saying and you can't expect other
you can't expect the world to give you
understanding you just can't unfold the
people that it didn't lead to that i had
a friend right and i'm not going to put
this business out here too tough but um
he had sort of a i think it was an auto
auto immune disease or he had some sort
of disorder um some sort of disease and
the medication from that disease caused
him to put on an extreme amount of
weight
what would you say to him
did it make him obese
not obese okay then uh
and that's what we're talking about
there's not many people like that
so i was gonna say i know people that
have had like medical issues um but yeah
we're not talking about those people and
i think we just have to have
understanding for that right we're
talking about the gen no but that's the
exception
yeah we're talking about like a couple
of thousands in millions and billions of
people i mean maybe i've exaggerated
there but we're talking about the masses
like the 90 percent you know the rest
the rest of civilization also it's only
those people but there's no there's no
there's no medication that makes you
obese
i mean i never said it was obese but it
just made him laugh i don't know retain
water or something okay
but there's a difference between putting
on weight right and then being
overweight so so i'm just trying to get
it clear that the main issue is that the
the presence of choice that's the main
thing
we're talking about people who are
saying you could be obese if it was like
i have a reason no no no no no no no no
no no the main the main issue is that we
don't hold women accountable and we
coddle them for poor choices right
that's right
that's that's the main issue and you
know what's funny probably if this was
any other context i really wouldn't even
disagree with you i really wouldn't be
having that internal battle that i would
be like yeah we do we do we do even
marketing
you know how certain products are
marketed it's it's
to
hold women in a way on certain things
but i just feel like in this regard it's
just too
i feel like if i didn't take this stance
no one would and it'll just be too
simple but the thing is what do you
think that people should
should do so you're saying that uh
people are coddled mm-hmm what is the
solution i suppose from you what i would
like to see is to get rid of movements
like body positivity and stop putting
these women on a pedestal for being fat
that's what i would like to see
i'd like to see women actually being
honest with each other and stop telling
their fat friend that nothing's wrong
that's that's what i would like to see
and